one of the best ways to start getting
more views on YouTube is by writing
better YouTube titles which can boost
the click-through rate on your videos
and ultimately help you trigger the
algorithm and potentially go viral and
we've been talking about YouTube titles
this is actually part two in a two-part
series of an Insider document that I
shared with the think media team trying
to kind of educate new people that have
been joining think media about how to
think about titles and here's one reason
why this is so powerful it's actually a
lot deeper than titles what it's really
about is understanding topics
understanding what viewers potentially
want to click on what they're interested
in and ultimately going to deeper levels
of understanding human behavior and
human psychology because we are creating
content for real people we're actually
not trying to reach the YouTube
algorithm we're not trying to reach a
robot we're not trying to reach the
YouTube algorithm is just a a robot it's
just a computer that is actually trying
to serve up the best content for people
and that's why we say at fake media the
Creator who understands the viewer best
wins and so we've been talking about it
ended up being nine tips I said 10 in
part one but it's actually nine things
that I shared with the think media team
I covered the first five so if you
haven't watched that episode you can
check it out at the end of this one
they're actually not in any particular
order but definitely make sure to listen
to that as well either on YouTube or on
the audio platforms for the podcast but
I'm excited to get into the next four
tips that I was really sharing with the
think media team and these were like
frames
to think about when coming up with
titles they're like spectacles like a
pair of lenses that you put on your eyes
when you're evaluating either a title
you're already written you've already
written or a title you're trying to come
up with so inside we're releasing almost
10 videos a week sometimes more at think
media so we're writing a ton of titles
so when we review them we're asking
ourselves these questions are they this
and they're probably not going to be all
nine of the things but as many of them
as you can tap into is going to make
your title that much more powerful and
so let's get into the next four and the
first one is the title creates curiosity
and it makes you want to click so your
question is how can you create curiosity
here's an example Heather did a video
uh titled this the top 10 secrets you
must know before starting a podcast now
this is kind of classic powerful
marketing and attention getting because
it's saying the top 10 Secrets like what
are the secrets what are the things I
must know so it's making kind of an
assumption right we are talking to a
specific audience and the specific
audience would be wanting to start a
podcast and then it's saying here's some
things you must know but I don't know
what the things are so the mystery is
that I gotta click on the video and
discover that inside of the video
one of the things that can hinder your
videos
is revealing the payoff in the title now
there's maybe a time to do that just
being really practical and clear but
your goal would ultimately be to create
a little mystery at times here's a video
that's Graham Stefan did and here's the
title why I stopped spending money dot
dot dot what's on the other side of that
now a disclaimer is that sometimes this
strategy works better once you have a
little bit of momentum because you know
people know who Graham Stefan is they
know who I is and there's a greater
context in story happening around him at
the time of posting that video
I'm following Graham for financial
advice why is he stopping money it's
probably some financial news that came
out it's probably something that
happened but nevertheless the question
is just to ask ourselves okay is this
title creating curiosity and at what
degree do I want to click am I apathetic
about it does it seem kind of flat does
it not really have any energy or emotion
around it or is it irresistible if it
was if I was scrolling through my
subscription feed or on my YouTube
homepage and of course a good thumbnail
is paired with it but then I read the
title and I'm like oh man I gotta know
what's on the other side of that then
you know you're on to something with a
powerful title number two it opens a
loop and it doesn't give the video away
now again this is a little bit similar
to curiosity but here's our goal is to
open a loop and so one of the videos I
did that really was quite popular was
actually a live stream but even after I
stopped going live the video went on to
get thousands of views I think it's over
a hundred thousand views and here's the
title YouTube employee reveals new
secrets for growing your channel dot dot
dot now let's break this down this is a
pretty powerful title and I've studied
copywriting and it's one of my things I
geek out on I like uh books from uh
Classics like ogilvion advertising and
and and those who learned how to use the
power of words to
um really get people to take action and
so the first thing here is YouTube
employee this is this Taps into
Authority
like okay you know it could be like your
mom review reveals new Secrets like
that's actually kind of funny but uh but
it probably wouldn't you know like I
don't know if your mom knows much about
YouTube you know what I mean so it's
like you could talk about you know my
neighbor reveals new Secrets but it's
YouTube employee so it's like okay I'm
getting someone from the inside and then
the the word reveals it's actually a
really powerful word it's actually one
of the power words so the YouTube
employee reveals like because that
insinuates mystery new new is another
powerful word that we like to use
because it's something we haven't heard
before and what we've learned is that we
as humans we love novelty we want the
new version right we want the new car we
want the new toothpaste we want the new
car smell we want the new strategies so
then you have secrets and that's more
mystery it opens a loop what are the
secrets and I'm not learning them in the
title four benefit it for the viewer
growing your channel my friend let is
let's break that down one two three four
five six seven eight nine words and dot
dot dot after it YouTube employee
reveals new secrets for growing your
channel now it might be important to
note at this moment a little bit of our
think media process
I want to encourage you that
um we don't just sit down and
necessarily come up with a great title
right at the start
um personally to come up with a great
title I typically have to write five to
ten and I just give it my best shot and
then I write another one and I write
them out for me I either write them in
Google Docs or I write them in slack and
I'm writing I'm talking to myself in
fact Saturdays when usually the think
media team is off this last Saturday I
went in there and I said title crew
which is what we call it when we have
our team actually brainstorm titles
together and I said title crew talking
to myself on a Saturday and I started to
do the title crew by myself like I was
alone I was all by myself and there I am
I'm just on a Saturday you know and I'm
pivoting a title actually in real time
which is something that you kind of
develop a sixth sense for you release
the video you see how it's doing in
performance and I'm like man I think it
could do better the content I feel like
is pretty good I don't feel like the
title is maybe powerful enough clickable
enough and sometimes you may want to
Pivot the thumbnail or you might want to
Pivot the title so I'm sitting down and
I'm I'm actually coming up with
alternative titles the video is already
released first thing in the morning I'm
waking up sipping copy coffee writing
titles you know it's my dream morning
honestly personally and
um I I'm I'm coming up with titles you
got to sit down and potentially
brainstorm multiple and so coming up
with YouTube employee reveals new
secrets for growing your channel if
that's like man that feels like a
challenge it can be challenging this is
like a muscle and a skill to develop and
work on and so I encourage you if you
want to come up with one good one write
at least four or five and then even look
at them by yourself and say which one of
these is best another thing you could do
is you could put it out there on social
media if you have a community tab or a
Facebook group or anywhere else where
you can do a poll right write three or
four
then put all four of them out there
where there's a poll feature on social
media and see if you could get 10 25 200
people to vote on that and a lot of
times it'll be a clear winner because
one thing we also realized and I
personally realize I'm also not as smart
as I think I can get so close to this
thing I might fall in love with the
title it doesn't mean it's the best one
so a lot of times our iron sharpens iron
when you can share titles even amongst
your social Community if you could share
it amongst one other person if you can
bounce it off a VA on your team or again
I know most of us are Solo creators if
you can just ask your partner or spouse
and say hey which one of these kind of
stands out the most to you or which one
of these makes you want to click the
most that could be a powerful way to
again open up a loop number two and not
give the video away and be really
compelling and interesting to make
people want to click one of the titles
from the sewing report Jennifer she's
one of our video ranking Academy
students she said watch this beef for
all caps watch this before starting an
Etsy Shop okay your desire
of the viewers to start an Etsy shop but
there's a little bit of drama here wait
a minute okay I know I want to start an
Etsy shop but before I gotta watch this
video before I do it now use these two
as some formulas you could fill in your
Niche like watch this before dating a
millennial watch this before
opening a business bank account watch
this before buying your first Airbnb or
rental property and you could fill that
in and and that's a powerful way to open
a loop that kind of makes me have to
click on that so your goal here is to
kind of make the viewer feel like
they're going to discover something in
the video or that there is a mystery to
be revealed number three here's a way to
think is does this title
frame a question that the viewer has
does it frame up a question the viewer
has Dave Ramsey had this title should I
buy a house or go to college now if
you've been hanging out with us on the
think media podcast for very long we
talk about the asq formula which is the
it stands for answer specific questions
one of the
potentially simplest ways to put a good
title out there is to just title the
video as a question and a specific
question
you know the more specific the better in
fact this is very specific because I
don't know it not a lot of people are
like Torn Between the idea of should I
buy a house or go to college but one of
the powerful things Dave Ramsey has is
he has a call-in show and because he's
actually answering the questions of real
people very specific questions are being
fed to him and so how can you just
create a title that just answers a
question by putting the question in the
title and sometimes we like to use a
combination at think media like it also
could be as simple as like feeling stuck
and so recently on I think a YouTube
short we were putting out there
feeling stuck question mark
watch this video to break through a
plateau on your YouTube channel
you're speaking to maybe a question
that's more of an emotion but it could
also be more practical like you know
what are the first steps for your Niche
so frame up a question that the viewer
has should I do a
Roth IRA or a traditional IRA it's a
question all right number four taps into
fear or pain now this is again important
to know when understanding human
behavior and understanding human
motivation
we as people are pretty much driven by
two things every day we want to get away
from pain
or we want to get closer to pleasure
and so if our content can help people
get away from pain or if our content can
help people get closer to pleasure and
in the first episode of this two-part
series we talked about you know helping
people reach their desires and their
Ambitions of course pain is usually the
problem that you're thinking about right
now what's keeping you up at night so
here's the title from Sin City Outdoors
uh this video got 820 000 views and
here's what it says Vegas water drought
three exclamation points what you should
know
now you can see how these are stacking
this is it actually is not set as a
question but one question that's on the
minds of people living on Vegas in Vegas
is are we running out of water
uh it's so there's also kind of an open
loop and there is ultimately some
curiosity like what you should know okay
I gotta click on this because there's
probably some facts in here some
information here that I need to know but
the lead of the title right is potential
fear and potential pain uh number one
it's scary to think that we might run
out of water number two it'll be
incredibly painful not to have water so
it's a it even this comes back to not
just how the title is written even into
the very topics you're talking about
themselves when you understand what are
the fears and the pain that your target
viewer the target audience the community
of people you want to reach are your
content is going to resonate more you're
going to be stunned by the way that your
content starts to really strike a chord
because there's an emotional connection
and it's what's top of mind for viewers
here's one from George Blair West this
was actually a TED Talk that got 500 000
views three ways to build a happy
marriage and to avoid divorce now let's
break this down three ways okay I'm
gonna learn something practical they
frame that up for me to build a happy
marriage amazing I'm getting closer to
pleasure and to avoid divorce I'm also
going to either get out of pain or I'm
going to have a anti-fragual you know
insurance against pain maybe my marriage
is fine I want it to be better but I
also want to avoid my blind spots or
potential things that could be coming
down the road do you see how powerful
this is now imagine weaving just some of
these strategies into your content
um I mentioned this title that really
crushed for us at think media and it was
an urgent warning for all content
creators again warning is a powerful
title
urgent
urgent warnings even more powerful okay
so uh there's a potential what do I need
to know here what's on the other side of
this so there's some this this Stacks
them all up by the way right it's
curiosity what's the warning it opens a
loop I've got a click like it doesn't
give the video away and then it Taps
into fear and pain it's like what's the
warning what am I avoiding here and
again our goal here is not to just
spread fear add up by any means and
there's even a term floating around it's
called fear porn and that's the idea of
the fact that in YouTube sometimes you
just see almost abuse in this area where
everyone's just kind of doing these
shocking headlines but I do think that
the extremes are avoiding that too much
when it's a powerful tool for growth and
I think the best way to do it is I hope
the way we're doing it at think media an
urgent warning for all content creators
talking to the real fears people have
but then here's our perspective we don't
have a spirit of fear we have a a spirit
of power love and a sound mind we have a
spirit of power love and clear thinking
we acknowledge the true challenges
facing us but then we also Embrace The
Hope and possibilities and the fact that
God has given us created creativity and
wisdom to be problem solvers here's the
cool thing did you know that Vegas is
actually the most efficient water city
in the world like I actually because of
like are we going to run out of water I
found myself on YouTube I watched a
25-minute documentary and I realize we
give more water back than we take and
it's actually the other states that are
draining the Colorado River and there's
going to be a committee that's going to
sit to figure out because it's an
Antiquated rules of who gets how much
water and they and what the video
revealed was actually more cities should
be like Vegas what was interesting is
oftentimes in the absence of Truth and
Clarity fear and anxiety remains and so
we hope that you being connected to the
think media podcast you don't just take
these tools and just go spread fear that
you tap into the real fears and
anxieties people have but then you
deliver hope truth solutions that you
deliver opportunities that you help
people realize that there's no it's no
good spending time in fear or worry what
we're pushing for is ultimately faith
hope and solutions and so when we add up
all of these again this was an eternal
document these are just some of the ways
we think about this at think media and
by the way I know that this was a lot
and I hope that this has been adding
value to you if it has definitely leave
me some feedback if you consume the
think media podcast on YouTube in the
comments which one of these did you like
best which one of these are you going to
apply to your content if you listen to
this on audio going to Apple podcasts
and leaving us a review and maybe
talking about this episode would be
super super meaningful and then also I
highly recommend our tube starter
kit.com that is our YouTube starter kit
and just one of the really cool it's
there's a bunch of thumbnail stuff and
in there there's a whole list of the
best video ideas to get started with
money making strategies but we have this
resource called the 15 best title
formulas so if you just want to kind of
copy paste some of our best titles
immediately into your videos that
resource alone makes this this is a very
low cost resource that'll just help you
revive or start a YouTube channel that
really makes an impact anyways you can
check it out at tubestarterkit.com it's
our YouTube starter kit it's a digital
asset bundle it's super cool but uh
check that out but let's just recap the
two um the entire list and then go
listen on episode number one of this
series so that you can learn some of the
nuances around each of these so here's
all nine that I share with the team
number one benefit driven features and
benefits number two unique and fresh how
can I make this title unique and fresh
number three does this title speak to
the desires and Ambitions of viewers
number four does this title call out a
specific audience like moms like content
creators like someone with an apple
shape body like first home home buyers
first-time home buyers number five does
this video agitate a problem the viewer
has and then make a promise to solve it
number six does the video create
curiosity does the title make you want
to click number seven does the video
open a loop does the title give the
video away so you're like okay I don't
need to watch that it says what it is or
does it actually create mystery that I
need to click on number eight does the
title frame a question that the viewer
has and the number nine can this title
tap into fear and pain or of course also
help the viewer get closer to pleasure
foreign